first time we're hearing from our Border
Patrol agent involved in a dramatic
scene that's come to symbolize u.s.
immigration policy the picture of a
Honduran girl crying as she and her
mother are detained in Texas has grabbed
people's attention worldwide Time
magazine put her on its cover but the
photo might be a little misleading in an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning the border agent shows us what
happened in the moments before was taken
David Pegg know was with us again from
McAllen David good morning good morning
you may have seen the photo who even
shared it on social media a lot of
people have there is some misinformation
surrounding what happened and we wanted
to try and clear it up all week we've
been trying to get an interview with
this Border Patrol agent to get his
account and so now you're about to hear
from the agent and the photographer who
were together for nearly ten hours on a
ride-along a lot of you have asked us
where are the mother and child right now
we can confirm that they are together
the federal government tells us they are
being housed at a facility in Texas
right now here now is the Border Patrol
agent who detained them we were
patrolling the border it was after 10
o'clock at night that is Border Patrol
agent Carlos Ruiz who says he was the
first to encounter Sandra Sanchez and
her young daughter after they allegedly
crossed the Rio Grande River into Texas
illegally we asked her to set the kid
down in front of her not away from him
she was right in front of her and so we
can properly search the mother so the
kid immediately started crying as he set
it down I personally went up to the
mother and asked her are you doing okay
he's a kid okay and she said yes she's
tired and thirsty
he's 11 o'clock at night when I took
this picture I knew it would be
important I had no way of knowing that
it would touch people quite on the level
that it has that's Getty photographer
John Moore who joined Ruiz for a nearly
nine hour ride along on the border
he was just feet from Sanchez and the
little girl I asked her how long she'd
been traveling and she gave me this very
weary look and she said she'd been on
the road with her daughter
for a month imagine doing that with with
children it's it's almost impossible to
imagine actually Moore's image is now on
the cover of Time magazine next to a
picture of the president they're using
it to symbolize a policy and that was
not the case on this picture it took
less than two minutes as soon as a
search was finished she immediately
picked the girl up and the girl
immediately stopped crying Moore says
Ruiz and other agents acted
professionally that night but he is
happy with the cover and the response to
the image oftentimes immigration is
talked about in terms of statistics and
when you put a human face and you
humanize an issue you make people feel
and when you make people feel they have
compassion and if I've done just a
little bit of that then that's okay we
are also fathers we are sons we are also
have families and we do care and we do
our jobs and we treat this people as who
mainly and as best as we possibly can so
we have more information about where the
mother and daughter are being kept right
now they are currently in the custody of
ice Immigration and Customs Enforcement
and they are being housed at the South
Texas family residential center in Dili
Texas now ice tells us in this statement
that immigration proceedings are ongoing
you should also know this ice says On
June 3rd 2013 the mother who you just
saw in that story was encountered
detained and arrested by immigration
officials in hebbronville Texas she was
transferred to ice custody in 2013 and
deported to Honduras and so they're
saying this is now her second time
coming into the country illegally again
she and the daughter are together and
Border Patrol says at no point where
they ever separated not in the custody
of Border Patrol and Isis saying they
haven't been separated in our custody we
have not been able to talk to the mother
we can only go by what the government
officials are telling us thank you very
much reporting